what's the one thing we're not talking  about that we really should be oh dude I  remember one time I saw these massive  Birds right they call them yeah it's  beautiful strong I went to this place  called Newcastle have you heard of this  yes yeah Newcastle and this taxi drops  me off there was a big room like a big  window and they were in there naked what  do you call a tits yes yes tits and they  were beating each other with pillows in  there bro and I sat out there and  watched smoked a cigarette out there and  that's the one thing no one's talking  about huh  there was seven of these women in there  I can see why you brought it up yeah  it was serious man oh